les sentinelles de l'oubli documentaire
réalisé par Jérôme prieur sa caméra vous
venez de le voir s'attarde longuement
sur ces monuments érigés un peu partout
en France à la sortie de la Grande
Guerre de la boucherie humaine que fut
la guerre de 1418 quel fut leur histoire
quel sens donner à leur place au cœur de
chaque commune française ou presque nous
allons y revenir maintenant avec nos
invités présents sur ce plateau de débat
dooc Jérôme prieur est avec nous
bienvenue Jérôme prieur c'est donc avoue
hein qu' l'on doit ce ce documentaire
consacré à ces monuments au morts c'est
sentinelles de l'oubli comme vous les
avez appelé vous êtes écrivain et
réalisateur auteur d'une vingtaine d'cè
et d'une bonne trentaine de films le
plus souvent à caractère historique vous
étiez sur ce même plateau il y a pas si
longtemps d'ailleurs pour nous parler
cette fois du Mur de l'Atlantique où là
aussi vous aviez réalisé un un
documentaire à ce sujet et puis je
renvoie tout simplement un nos
téléspectateurs à votre filmographie
Annette Becker est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes historienne des
guerres contemporaines et des génocides
vous êtes l'auteur entre autres de ce
livre les monuments au Morts patrimoine
et mémoire de la grande guerre c'était
aux éditions errance et votre dernier
ouvrage s'intitule messager du désastre
publié chez Fayard et consacré à Raphaël
Lemkin et à Yan karsky lanceur d'alerte
inaudible pendant la Choa c'est donc à
découvrir chez Fayard Jérôme prieur
pourquoi vous êtes-vous intéressé à ces
fameux monument au m enfant j'ai voulu
écrire un livre sur la guerre de 14
queheureusement ce projet je ne l'ai pas
mené à bien mais qu'il y a quelques
années j'ai écrit mes souvenirs c'est
c'est ironique de la guerre de 14 un
livre qui s'appelle la moustache du
soldat inconnu et je me suis rendu
compte que finalement tout autour de
nous cette guerre qui semble très
lointaine le centenaire l'a rendu encore
enc plus vieille peut-être cette guerre
là qui est qui est qui est très
lointaine elle est tout autour de nous
comme vous l'avez dit elle est elle est
présente à travers tous ces monuments au
morts il y en a quasiment un par commune
plus parfois dans certains endroits et
que parmi ces monuments au morts que
Annette Becker a été l'une des premières
d'ailleurs à étudier
historiquement parmi ces monuments au
Morts bah il y en a qui se répètent qui
sont pareils qui
sont peu peu extraordinaire et mais il y
en a quelques-uns qui m'ont toujours
extrêmement frappé et donc au long de
mes voyages à travers la France mais
depuis longtemps ENF c'est bien
antérieur au film je n'ai eu de cesse
que de que de les regarder de les
photographier et puis un beau jour je me
suis dit il faut que je fasse quelque
chose il faut que je je suis cinéaste il
faut que je fasse à partir de ces
monuments de cette statuaire qui est
très inventive de cette fantasmagorie en
relief que je fasse un film et voilà
j'ai réussi à le faire avant de vous
donner la parole àette Becker on va
recontextualiser hein ce qui a été cette
guerre et et les morts hein de cette
guerre regardez ce petit tableau alors
les chiffres sont contestés contestables
c'est il est très difficile hein de
comptabiliser les les morts à l'occasion
de de de cette guerre la fourchette
généralement retenue se situe entre 9 et
10 millions de morts à l'occasion de ce
conflit uniquement concernant les
militair hein et non pas les les civils
alors c'est beaucoup ce chiffre c'est
énorme euh néanmoins la Seconde Guerre
mondiale a fait du côté des militaires
deux fois plus de victimes plus de 20
millions de victimes pour la seconde
guerre mondiale hein en comparaison et
cette seconde guerre mondiale a aussi
fait je crois près de 80 millions de
victimes si on y ajoute les les civiles
et puis regardeer les morts du côté
français sur ce même graphique 1,4
million de morts du côté des militaires
français
euh lors de ce conflit et
4,2 millions de blessés c'est à titre
comparatif là aussi le la Seconde Guerre
mondiale avait fait 250000 morts du côté
des militaires français on mesure la
différence qu' a représenté qu'on
représenté ces ces deux conflits dans
dans l'esprit des Français c'est
peut-être là par par où il faut
commencer pour bien comprendre ce qu'on
été ces monuments morts érigés après
cette fameuse guerre de 1418 oui tout à
fait et ce que j'aime beaucoup dans le
dans le film justement c'est que le film
s'intéresse au aux hommes et aux femmes
un peu moins mais surtout au aux hommes
qui ont fait ce combat et donc qui ont
consenti qui ont détesté qui ont haïi
et le le résultat c'est ce deuil immense
sur la société d'une certaine manière
est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'on a humanisé
ce combat à travers ces monuments aux
morts alors on a enfin pensé aux hommes
qui l'ont fait cette gu il y a des
monuments morts partout non seulement en
France mais dans le monde entier une
guerre mondiale des monuments partout et
donc on voit bien que c'est une façon de
réfléchir à l'épreuve extraordinaire qui
vient de se passer qui est partout mais
la France a une spécificité c'est qu'il
y en a plus qu'ailleurs il y en a plus
qu'ailleurs 95 % des 36000 communes
françaises ont un monument au mais non
seulement les 36 1000 communes mais vous
multipliez par le nombre d'églises par
le nombre de temples par le nombre de
synagogues par le nombre d'usines par le
nom d'École partout il y a eu des
combattants et partout on veut se les
remémorer et et donc ça montre bien que
le le la mort la blessure la façon dont
on est mort c'est une façon
tellement extraordinaire que on veut
absolument que ça soit présent et ce qui
est intéressant dans dans le le
documentaire c'est qu'il montre à la
fois les monuments des communes qui
n'ont pas d'argent et qui donc achètent
sur catalogue quelque chose d'un petit
peu banal on dirait parce que ça sera
aussi un commerce mais c'est ai un
commerce mais tout est un commerce
Bertrand Tavernier dans la vie rien
d'autre l'a montré dans un dans un film
de fiction
remarquable bien sûr bien sûr que c'est
un commerce mais avant d'être un
commerce c'est
l'expression du fait que l'on a perdu
des hommes en nombre extraordinaire et
que ceux qui les ont perdu les veuves
les orphelins la société toute entière
leurs camarades de combat qui sont
encore vivants quelquefois des
sculpteurs qui ont échappé à la mort
tout le monde veut que ça soit visible
et donc ce qui était invisible pendant
la guerre on savait pas très bien on on
se doutait bien parce que ça arrivait
les télégramme mais on avait pas une
idée du chiffre et à ce moment-là les
monuments aux morts viennent
figer ficher la mort absolument partout
l'époque d'or des m morts ce sont les
années 20 c'est tout de suite après la
guerre et c'est et c'est logique c'est
c'est c'est le moment où le le deuil est
le plus est le le plus frais et très
souvent les conseils municipaux euh
déclarent qu'ils feront un monument aux
morts l'année 1918 n'est pas terminé la
guerre s'arrête le 11 novembre et dès le
mois de décembre 1918 dès le mois de
janvier 1919 on décide qu'on fera un
monument au mort alors après il faut le
construire et cetera ça devient plus
compliqué on y reviendra peut-être tout
mais la décision est prise tout de suite
bien évidemment on va voir un extrait du
documentaire Jérôme prieur euh parce que
c'est la première fois qu'il a une forme
d'égalité à travers ces monuments au
morts c'est expliqué dans votre film la
première fois systématique
regardez pour la première fois c'est
systématique les guerriers inconnus ont
le droit d'être nommés et pas seulement
les chefs de
guerre les simples soldats les
sous-officiers et les officiers sont
logés à la même enseigne les paysans les
ouvriers les citadins les pauvres et les
riches tous les contingents d'hommes
envoyés au
feu pour la première fois
systématiquement vous l'avez dit les
guerrions on eu le droit d'être nommés
pas seulement les chefs de guerre et
c'est vrai que quand on voit ces
monuments on voit très souvent
d'ailleurs des des plusieurs frères qui
ont été tués au combat bon ils sont tous
là les des non figures le symbolisme est
fort là aussi non oui puis c'est
vraiment dans des coins les plus
éloignés de la zone des combats on va en
Corse on voit des litanies de nom enfin
c'est on sent que des familles ont été
décimées littéralement au sens littéral
donc ça c'est très frappant mais
j'ajouterai quelque chose par rapport à
ce que ce qui vient d'être dit par
Annette Becker ce qui m'a beaucoup
frappé que j'avais pas très bien réalisé
avant de faire le film c'est à quel
point ces monuments au morts sont une
façon de d'honorer les morts et aussi de
rendre hommage aux vivants aux
survivants aux poilu survivants qui
veulent qu'on leur garde leur place
d'honneur dans la société mais aussi que
ces monuments morts sont une façon de de
réunir les morts il faut bien comprendre
que en 1920 il y a un grand débat euh en
France de savoir si les morts qui sont
morts sur le champ de bataille on peut
les rapatrier dans leur petite patrie
dans le leur commune ou s'ils doivent
rester avec leurs camarades de combat et
donc finalement on décide que les morts
pourront être rapatriés chez eux ce qui
coûte cher et ce qui n'est pas le le le
au pouvoir de toutes les familles donc
il y a les morts qui sont sur les champs
de bataille il y a les morts qui sont
rapatriés dans leur village et puis et
puis il y a un nombre incroyable enfin
celui-là on le connaît pas aujourd'hui
on narrive pas à le connaître il y a un
nombre incroyable de soldats inconnus
pas le soldat inconnu
est l' de Triomphe il y a 300000 400000
500000 morts Inn vous dites même dans
votre film un mort sur 4 n'a pas pu être
identifié oui les historiens sont on a
lancé des évaluations au lendemain de la
guerre de 14 pour savoir combien il y en
avait quoi il y a ceux dont on a que le
nom il y a ceux dont on a que les restes
il y a ceux dont on a rien et donc je
pense moi c'est l'hypothèse que je fais
dans le film que les monuments au mort
c'est une façon de réunir les morts qui
sont sur les champs de bataille qui sont
dans leur cimetière mais aussi tous ces
soldats inconnus de faire de donner des
funérailles à tous ces soldats quels
qu'ils soi alors ce qu'on apprend aussi
dans votre film c'est que seuls les
monuments des grandes batailles sont à
l'initiative de l'État à l'époque mais
qu'en revanche les autres sont à la de
la responsabilité des municipalités avec
une éventuelle subvention de l'État pour
at des morts et de la taille de la
commune euh vous me parliz tout à
l'heure de voilà ils ont il a fallu les
construire il y avait aussi un enjeu
politique on l' très bien compris dans
ce film parce
que les anciens combattants
représentaient une part importante du
corps électoral comment les choses se
sont passées là je pense qu'il faut
minimiser le côté politique je veux pas
dire qu'il n'existe pas et il y a même
des des sculpteurs qui ont des opinions
politiques qu' font passer sur les
monuments mais je crois qu'il faut le
minimiser il faut bien voir que de la
société toute entière il y a une une
demande de tombe de tombe pour
aller auprès de ce qu'on a perdu or ils
sont soit dans les cimetières militaires
et un certain nombre après 1920 parce
que les gens crient au scandale on veut
on les a donné certains disent à la
Chambre des députés euh on les a donné
pour la France et maintenant on veut les
avoir pour que notre deuil soit dans
notre cimetière communale mais ça
coûtait cher même s'il y avait des
subventions et donc c'est finalement
surtout les officiers de familles plus
aisé qui ont été rapatriés et le
Monument au Morts était pour tous les
autres et le Monument au Morts c'est un
cénotaf c'est un tombeau vide il faut le
voir comme un tombeau c'est pour cela
que ça ressemble pour les plus simples à
des monuments de cimetière tout
simplement on vient au tombeau
de ceux qui sont morts mais ils sont
morts pour la patrie pour la France ils
sont morts victimes de la guerre ils
sont morts pour leur commune et c'est
intéressant de voir cela parce que on
dit très souvent les fils de la France
ou les fils de la commune or normalement
ils ont entre 20 et 45 ans devrait pas
être mort et c'est leurs parents qui
vient
prier devant leur tombe prier au sens
religieux ou simplement exercer montrer
leur affliction épouvantable alors on
fait la quête aussi il y a souvent des
initiatives paroissiales he qui qui
provoquent les initiatives
communales pour bah trouver de l'argent
tout simplement hein pour financer ces
fameux bien sûr parce que tout ça ça
coûte cher alors tout ça comme le dit
extrêmement bien le film avec beaucoup
de de de de finesse ça donne du travail
à toutes sortes de corps de métierou et
bah les architectes les les les gens qui
taillent les pierres les ferronniers et
cetera et je crois qu'au-delà de
cela
cela une fois de plus rassemble toute
cette France de l'époque tous les
métiers possibl et imaginaable sont
aussi autour du monument au mort alors
je sais pas combien de monuments au mort
vous avez visité ion de ce film je
rajoute d'ailleurs que là on voit une
version courte he de votre documentaire
il y a une version de 90 minutes qui qui
existe ce film qui sortira en salle et
d'ailleurs je conseille à tous ceux qui
nous regardent d'aller voir ce film en
salle parce queévidemment le rendu n'est
pas du tout le même hein compenu du
parti prix cinématographique quasiment
hein que vous avez eu dans dans ce ce
documentaire bon ce n'est pas politique
me dites-vous je vous entends je vous
écoute mais dans le documentaire il est
dit que voilà voilà il y a aussi ces
monuments très patriotiques don on peut
supposer qu'il viennent de de finalement
peut-être de Mair de
municipalités plus patriotes et puis il
y a des monuments à l'inverse
complètement
pacifistes il y avait vous avez observé
dans tous ces monuments que vous avez pu
pu voir ce ce ce genre de différence ce
genre d'approche ben pour donner des
chiffres on a filmé à peu près 200 300
monuments et on a parcouru 9000 km en
tournant en quatre saisons quoi
c'est-à-dire c'est vraiment un travail
important et j'aurais pu continuer parce
qu'il y a des régions dans lesquelles je
ne suis pas allé ça ça coûte cher de
faire un film et donc il y a des il y a
des territoires que je n'ai pas exploré
ce qui frappe c'est la diversité de ce
que vous diversité et en même temps il y
a des il y a des rimes il y a des
récurrences enfin il y a des thèmes il y
a une thématique et c'est ça qui
m'intéressait de construire le film
comme si les monuments étaient les
roches d'un d'un film imaginaire qui
n'aurait jamais étit monté pourquoi les
roches parce que il y a plusieurs il y a
plusieurs veuves et pleoré il y a
plusieurs scènes de combat il y a
plusieurs soldats qui portent le drapeau
il y a il y a les il y a les statues qui
pratiquent la série et puis il y a
toutes les œuvres originales certaines
sont dues à des petits artisans et puis
d'autres sont du à des grands à des
grands sculpteurs enfin il y en a que
j'ai vraiment qu'on connaît enfin comme
Paul lamowski par exemple mais il y a un
sculpteur moi qui me touche infiniment
qui a fait le monument à comanterie à
Chalon en Champagne qui est Gaston
Broquet qui qui a qui au valde grâce qui
qui travaille le la fonte enfin c'est
extraordinaire avec des sculteurs pour
beaucoup qui avaient eux-même participé
au combat il y en a beaucoup qui sont
des anciens combattants et qui
témoignent pour leur camarades
finalement et puis il y en a d'autres
qui n'ont pas vu les qui n'ont pas vu le
feu comme on dit par exemple à barleduc
qu'il y a un monument très très beau que
j'ai filmé et on a l'impression que le
sculpteur était là et en réalité il
était pas là quoi bon parce que ce sont
des artistes il y en a qui sont géniaux
quoi on peut dire ouais Annette bcker
vous attardez d'ailleurs hein sur cette
diversité dans dans votre ouvrage
consacré au monument mort vous dites il
y a la faucheuse le gisant le poilus
sucombant au feu ou encore les parents
et pleurer surtout la mer assimilable à
la République on l'a très bien vu
d'ailleurs ça dans le film et puis à
amamel il y a un monument qui n'est
autre qu'une Piéta hein si proche de
Michelange dites-vous euh oui bien sûr
euh l'idée est que euh je le redis ce
sont des lieux du du deuil euh et donc
forcément le deuil euh va aller avec les
pratiques religieuses et dans une France
encore largement catholique et bien cela
va être la Vierge la matère de leorosa
la la Piéta c'est bat matère et
évidemment alors qu'à priori aucun signe
religieux n'était autorisé sur ces
monuments voilà bien sûr on est après la
loi de séparation des églises et des
états et donc aucun signe religieux
n'est possible mais on tourne la loi
très facilement d'une part en les
mettant à proximité de l'église et là ça
permet d'utiliser la croix de l'église
qui se retrouve comme la croix du du
monument ou
alors bien évidemment c'est la la façon
dont on représente les personnages et
donc Marianne c'est aussi une croyance
et je dirais que quelque
part le coq qu'on entend d'ailleurs très
souvent dans la musique et ça c'est une
chose magnifique dans cette musique qui
est une musique composée mais avec des
bruits de guerre ou des bruits de paix
comme le coq le coq pensons que c'est
une France encore largement rurale et
c'est pour cela que dans les les plus
petits villages qui aujourd'hui ont
quasi disparu il y a ces longues listes
et donc le coq c'est galous évidemment
qui rappelle par une erreur d'étymologie
Galia la gaaule mais c'est aussi cette
France paysane et c'est celle-là d'abord
qui a donné ou été obligé de donner tous
ces morts à à la guerre et c'est ça
qu'on retrouve sur les monuments et puis
on retrouve évidemment le combattant
presque toujours donc on a croire
combattre et puis très souvent des
femmes au travail parce que c'est les
femmes qui ont pendant la guerre été le
front domestique le front de l'intérieur
si elle n'avait pas travaillé dans les
usines si elle n'avait pas tenu la
charue la guerre s'arrêtait
immédiatement ce n'était Ctait pas
possible sans les femmes et donc les
monuments sont plus sophistiqués qu'ils
n'en ont l'air bien sûr on voit avant
tout des soldats au combat c'est ceux
qui sont les plus nombreux mais quand on
les regarde avec la finesse de ce film
on voit tout de suite que c'est bien
plus compliqué et la présence des femmes
la présence des femmes en particulier
dans les départements
envahis dans les départements occupés
me paraît particulièrement importante on
voit à un moment le monument de de poid
du Nord où il y a une une civile qui est
prise dans les pierres écroulées de son
village c'est le monument au mort c'est
une femme mais à cet endroit-là les
civils étaient occupés les civils
étaient aussi en première ligne donc si
on regarde bien on voit pas seulement
l'idée de l'union sacrée en pierre qui
est mais il y a plein de détails
absolument qui montre la différence de
la France on voit des Bretonnes en
Bretagne des Savoyards dans Savoie des
Basques au Pays-Basque on voit tout le
régional aussi tout le local chacun se
réapproprie le monument au mort parce
qu'il se réapproprie son propre mort et
vous en parlez avec beaucoup de passion
c'est fini Jérôme prieur vous voulez
rajouter un mot mais c'est vraiment un
mot hein que sur le rôle des femmes
c'est un peu plus modéré c'est-à-dire
que les femmes elles sont là dans leur
rôle éternel un peu et que les le le
nouveau rôle compris les femmes grâce à
la guerre de 14 il est peu présent elles
sont présentes mais dans une vision un
peu archaïque qu'elles occupent dans la
société merci beaucoup cette fois c'est
la fin un grand merci à tous les deux
spécialement à vous Jean pryur pour ce
film que vous nous avez livré en
exclusivité pour cette émission des
Badoc Ann Becker on vous retrouvera avec
plaisir à une autre occasion dans cette
même émission des Badog vos réactions
euh ça sera bien sûr sur hashtagdbadog
merci à selmali qui m'a aidé à préparer
cette émission comme à l'accoutumé je
vous donne tout simplement rendez-vous
pour un prochain lesbadoc et ça sera
bien entendu avec son documentaire et
son débat à
[Musique]
bientôt